[Music]
in fatal error news oh that's like a
doctor's biggest nightmare doesn't seem
like a tech thing but like that could be
oh that works - she's pretty morbid
yeah I'm pretty realistic you face it
did say fatal battle there all I see
from my angle is just his [ __ ]
jellybean head somebody said like you
you [ __ ] face I'd be like okay yeah
all I see here is just like face no neck
just face yeah so what three-year-old
says it's [ __ ] time submitted by
Marilyn loves JK hey Marilyn is it this
day it's me yeah melon a 27 year old
woman was accidentally embalmed alive
Jesus Christ oh wait I heard about this
like hooking up like the brain take it
out and everything yeah mummy style
right the the medication that they use
it doesn't make sense though cuz I
didn't know they did that for mommy I no
way I actually know exactly what
happened in there I thought they'd like
if the person passes then they go what I
thought - I didn't know that they kept
saline and formaldehyde in the same
shelf like what would be this is this is
this the part of real life where the
theme that the stuffed animal grabber
comes and then grabs the human picks up
the human and then throws him in a fish
tank full of you be a little bit more
sensitive what the [ __ ] wait when have
you heard that happening that happen I
think he's mixing up two things on [ __ ]
an arcade clog yeah
you thinking about the matrix fool I
know he's coming from a real place
started this sexy love matrix with in
real life you know when you're born and
stuff and that [ __ ] spine comes out
your back capture like so did you guys
take the red pill it blue pill it's
crazy when you came out the pool um okay
okay it was formaldehyde but like did
anyone ever hear that rumor this is like
when those dumb rumors you hear when
you're an elementary school that diet
coke had formaldehyde in it really into
smart elementary school
Mountain Dew makes you dick small
elements we talked about the [ __ ]
ghosts that haunted the bathroom that's
like the Arlen a Bloody Mary
yeah I think one of our rumors was that
like Marilyn Manson had a rib removed so
he could say Marilyn Manson where are
you from i from California Virginia
Virginia yeah that's crazy
oh you're younger healthy huh 26 Marilyn
Manson over there every time over here
and different drivers and I still don't
know if it's true
can he suck his own dick I thought he
did suck his own dick no cuz he removed
his ribs no that's just fact look at
this Marilyn Monroe can suck your own
dick huh I just I just searched
Marilyn and then as a Manson give
himself head like so many people okay we
know we need to know these days yeah
yeah out of all people why did everyone
choose him to pick up cuz he's the crazy
one like he was also with like Rose
McGowan and like they [ __ ] did a bunch
of [ __ ] on like raw meat or something
like that like you was just out there
what rolling the gums and he'll ass girl
right yeah yeah
when you say a couple did a bunch of
stuff on raw meat I'm like why I just
knew it was something with a Gras meat
and like it was sexual I just can't
remember the details past that's one of
those deal-breakers that's like baby I
got this fantasy that's are you drugged
alive yeah Marilyn Manson was already
Marilyn Manson when they met so I'm
pretty sure she knew what she was
getting you know it wasn't like the
beginnings he has already had his brandy
he already had the to colorize I know
what that means Rose McGowan she's her
agent typecasted her into something that
she is not a charm yeah I mean wait oh
yeah she's super pretty though innocent
she's very pretty very pretty she looks
like she's a kingster though Mike King
like she's like into kinky weird [ __ ]
that is an interesting term yeah it's
okay I want to hear about the Mountain
day there was a film with me called
Shortbus where a guy it is own Cubs
anyways like huh it was like a film yet
cuts all Shortbus have you guys heard of
it it was like it was like crazy talked
about just because they have like
full-on like frontal sex and [ __ ] what
is parental said like full-on just
straight-up like movie sex that's real
sex
so porn like real sex in a film like
this use up my old phrase
stir my god so I just thought it was
cute what the [ __ ] it's cute
[ __ ] I got a real question for
you guys
yep what the back version of frontal is
it back total [ __ ] back side no one
else no what's the back version of it I
give that back though back backside
nudity no because it'll be front side
then that's the man part is it Gio was
like no TIF let's go on with the story
of a tip was still trying to like trying
to [ __ ] wrangle it what about the
mountain on a silver platter she said
this battle that [ __ ] from the back
always looks better than [ __ ] on the
front yup
like no matter what a nice little weight
to it no he is not good-looking isn't
this no it's not especially has a little
bit of stubble sometime soon
stubble are you [ __ ] serious like
this that's so [ __ ] funny
I never did anybody describes table is
like a little cactus that's what it is
yeah that's real sweet though that's
sweet
yeah so this lady I couldn't find what
maybe you guys can write in the comments
if you find it cuz in this very short
amount of time I had to research this I
couldn't find the answer to Marilyn
Manson sucking his own dick anyway this
woman from Russia she
she'd go in for please don't say it was
like I don't know an ingrown toenail
would you mind [ __ ] melted my ass I
was gonna say the same [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of my brain [ __ ] yeah they're
saying that she went in for an
unspecified but routine surgery let's
hear it say butt butt surgery dancer
wishes not that is she she is that could
she was involved I thought it was in the
process if you get him bummed that's it
that's a [ __ ] rat Bart literally it's
a rat Katrina
mmm yeah so she are all Russian so she
was placed on a formal formalin drip
instead of a saline drip you know it's
even more [ __ ] up but apparently more
than her dying Louie yeah mourn because
apparently the hospital staff found this
out and the mom is claiming that the
hospital staff weren't doing anything
about it but they weren't trying to like
save her up and like hours later then
they were trying to save her so she got
plugged into a [ __ ] bag of liquid that
said formally and on there and they
found that out on their life will [ __ ]
we'll just let it keep dripping didn't
swap the bag on immediately wouldn't you
want me to do it and how we start trying
to like save her after all eh yeah oh
[ __ ] ton of drugs a fifty two drugs in a
desperate attempt to save her because
more Mountain formaldehyde does it it
stops the body from decomposing so it's
kind of like freezes the organs as they
are which for a living person that kills
you yeah that's bad so her mom was
saying that her legs were moving that
she had convulsions her entire body was
shaking and that she was trying to keep
her warm because they didn't like she
didn't know why she was shaking so much
and then finally she overheard the
doctors say that they made a medical air
like a medical mistake we [ __ ] up they
said they said that loud
front of her what's off [ __ ] like
whispering that [ __ ] organs stop started
failing dude just kill me now surprised
that they keep the formalin in the
Saline next to each other nonetheless in
the same room like they should have like
a dead people in like an alive people
over there like you know what I would
have done if I was a doctor I want to
blame like oh it was a factory mix-up
you don't keep those things together and
I would been like Brenda name Brenda
you're not a [ __ ] doctor but you like
already but you're a liar I look G oh
I'm sure with a little bit of schooling
I would change my ways and I would be an
upstanding citizen there's so
disorganized over there can you sue
somebody in Russia there's no such thing
as suing oh yeah I don't know or do they
just like there is a criminal
investigation going on you have cops in
Russia weird video footage is the [ __ ]
yeah that country is so insane yeah
that's why everyone's dashcam yeah you
see where they just like get out of the
car like beat each other up like alright
what settled me just get back in the car
dash cam footage of like cops
interacting with civilians and they came
them right and they just walk away
they don't even arrest them it was just
like a normal Monday yeah what the [ __ ]
about all the crazy [ __ ] that the cat
like that meteor that they just having a
catch is interesting man I don't want to
go though save
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]